welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled detection
and treatment prediction of pancreatic
cancer
using a glycan biomarker it's my
pleasure to introduce you to dr brian
hobb
dr hogg is a professor in the center for
cell biology at the van handle institute
in grand rapids
michigan his research is on the
identification and detection of subtypes
of pancreatic cancer using glycan
biomarkers
the laboratory studies blood plasma
tumor tissue and cyst fluid using the
novel glycan analysis technologies to
deliver
biomarkers for early and more accurate
diagnosis
and improve prediction of tumor behavior
and drug responses
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen if you have
any questions that arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker
will address your questions following
the presentation
please join me now in welcoming dr brian
hobb i will now turn the presentation
over to him
welcome sir thank you very much for the
introduction and the opportunity to
present our work
before you today appreciate
participating in this
interesting symposium it's my pleasure
to tell you about
some work we've done on a new biomarker
that looks like it has a lot of promise
for the detection and treatment
prediction
of pancreatic cancer i'm going to
begin by telling you a bit of
background on the biomarker how we
discovered it
first of all disclosure of no conflicts
of interest
to disclose um
i'm going to give you a uh overview on
how we discovered this biomarker
and some of the work we've done on it on
initial validation
and um tell you about the
foreseen clinical applications in
pancreatic cancer
and uh give you an overview of the
results to date
and validation of the biomarker
to begin this is a glycan so it's
it's a um an oligosaccharide
we've named it stra for
sileated tumor-related antigen and we
discovered it with the hypothesis
that there are glycans that are related
to the ca199 glycan that could
also be biomarkers of pancreatic cancer
so ca199 is the current best
test for pancreatic cancer it's up in
some other
cancers as well it's made in the normal
pancreas in some individuals
it is a quatra saccharide so it's made
of four monosaccharides
there are a number of people who do not
elevate it in
cancer for whatever reason some because
they don't genetically make it others
because they have a subtype of
pancreatic cancer that doesn't
produce the ca 99 glycan
overall when a test is used at about a
25
false positive rate amongst benign
diseases
uh picks up about 75 percent of
the cancers in the blood so that
translates to a 75
specificity and sensitivity on average
over many studies now the
antibody that detects this glycan that's
called the ca199 antibody that's why
it's named that
was discovered in 1979 when the antibody
was originally generated
it wasn't known what it bound it was
through some more research over the next
few years was discovered to be a
oligosaccharide and then the structure
of it was found to be
the structure that you see on this slide
here
as a member of the what's called the
lewis flat
blood group family of
glycans so
we realized that if there are any
modifications to this structure
changes that the antibody would no
longer bind so the hypothesis was that
there are other glycants related to it
that are not bound by the cni 10
antibody but
are produced by pancreatic cancers so if
we
had ability to detect these
other family members we might be able to
detect more
pancreatic cancers so we undertook a
survey of related structures to the cnh9
we
used glycan profiling on ship this was
about four years ago four or five years
ago we began
this work it's it's a combination of
using capture antibodies on antibody
microarrays combined with
various detection reagents that detect
glycans in the lewis family
and it's nice because you can detect a
lot of combinations
of antibody and detection lectins
over many blood samples or tissue
samples so it's a
it's a nice highly parallel and high
throughput method
so screening through a number of
different potential glycans
to that could be biomarkers
we came up with some good candidates and
this is a summary slide here
from our 2016 publication where
we have the patients in the columns
and the various potential biomarkers in
the rows
and a red box means the
these are blood samples a red box means
the level was above
a high specificity threshold set for
that
row at one false positive so you see on
the right side are the controls
and there's one red box in each row
so the threshold was set to give
high specificity low false positives and
um you can see here that the top row uh
slea is the technical term for the
antigen bound by ca-99 so the top row is
ca199
and you can see at this high specificity
there's a fairly low sensitivity there's
a lot of yellows meaning there's a lot
of patients who are not elevated in it
um but what you can notice here is that
for the
patients many of the patients that are
not elevated in c99 they
are elevated um in some of these other
rows these are other glycans in a family
member family the lewis family and we
focused in particularly on one that um
was related to ca-99 and that it
did not have a fucos like ca199 but yet
it was built off the type one chain we
get a technical
abbreviation for it here um
and you can see that it it picks up both
in
early stage cancer which we defined in
stage one or two which is resectable
cancer
and late in both of those it picks up a
lot of the ones that are not detected by
c9
so more information on the structure
here's the
um both the three-dimensional
representations as well as the
symbolic cartoon graphs of the
antigens themselves c9 and
stra so again you can appreciate that
they're built off the same
core structure the beta three linkage
between the galactose and the
n-acetyl glucosamine defines what's
called a type
one um an acetyl-lactosamine linkage
which is less common than the type ii
which is the beta-4 linkage um and it's
missing the fucos and it's interesting
that this antigen without the stylic
acid
is um widely known to be
a marker for germ cells so embryonic
stem cells and tumors arising out of
embryonic germline tumors
so um it seems to have a stem
characteristic to it a marker for a stem
cell
uh with the stylic acid added so that
that is an indicator right there that it
could be a
subtype marker
so what we noticed about this as i said
was
that it picked up um a different group
of cancers some overlapping but some
different
than the ones that were elevating ca-99
so
really the question at that point became
is there a difference between the
cancers
that are elevating stra versus those
that are c199
and can they be used in combination
firstly to
detect more cancers of any kind secondly
to differentiate between
two different subtypes of cancers uh so
uh we began by looking at primary tumor
tissue
and we stained the primary tissue for
the presence of these glycans
comparing the morphologies of the cancer
cells that express
one or the other and any other
information we could get
on a molecular expression that could
characterize the two
types of tumors and so you can see here
that there are some tumors that express
primarily one or primarily the other or
both or neither
so the orange staining is the c 99 cyan
is the stereo and green is overlap
and so we have the raw fluorescence data
uh followed by the overlaid of the
glycan on the h e and then just a
picture of the h
e next to it so you can see the cell
morphology
we found that overlooking over many many
tumor
samples in multiple tmas this is our
2017 publication there were
morphological differences between
the tumors that expressed primarily stra
versus those that were neither or
c 199 stress tended to be
have a foamy large cytoplasm or
to be poorly defined
small incipient glands or invasive
glands
the cn189s tended to be the
well-differentiated
epithelial ducts with structural
structurally intact
functional glands the ones that
producing neither were a different
stripe
altogether it seemed
so we had strong morphological and some
molecular co-staining
with other differentiation markers that
we had
two different subtypes so um
what was important was that the plasma
levels correlated with the primary tumor
levels we had
about 45 matched samples where we had
blood samples with some matched tissue
so we could look at the correlation
between the tissue levels
in the primary tumor and the blood and
uh you see just as these few examples
here
where we had a tumor standard variety
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma with a
highly fibrotic background
in the upper left that stains with c9
and that in the blood on the right
where we have the x-axis the c-99 blood
level the y-axis
the stra blood level you can see that it
uh primarily
is elevated in the blood and c99 only
but not stra
and then um in the in the image labeled
number two
it's the opposite it's more on the
y-axis on that graph
and the one labeled number three is
elevated in both in the blood meaning
that the blood sample can be a good
indicator of the primary tumor level
which means then that a blood test could
be used to assess
the um the staining or the tissue
expression in the primary tumor
and we've also found this to be the case
in cell lines
and in xenographs both
aligned xenographs as well as
patient-derived xenographs
where the level on the cell line
correlates with the level in the media
or in the
mouse serum and that all is published
in our 2019 publication
so the next step here was to define
areas of application to pancreatic
cancer
and we're looking at two different areas
one
is detection or diagnosis
and the other is treatment prediction
and so detection diagnosis detection
what we mean by that is
detecting pancreatic cancer when there's
no
evidence of any cancer or any disease so
this would be
outwardly healthy asymptomatic people
but
possibly from a high risk category
diagnosis means that there's some
symptoms suggestive of a problem and for
differentiating
benign disease from cancer the
prediction
refers to somebody who has been
diagnosed
with pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
and is selecting treatment route
so for the um detection and diagnosis
the main goal here is to get a high
specificity
so that when it's used in practice
the number of false positives are
greatly minimized so
to reduce the extra burden on
follow-up testing but then at the same
time we want a high enough
sensitivity so that we're detecting
enough of the cancers
to make it worth applying to
to the population who's targeted ca199
can be a very highly specific test
at high cutoffs but the problem there is
that the sensitivity is so
low at high cutoffs so when you raise
the threshold to give you a 95
specificity and a background of
potentially
confounding diseases like pancreatitis
and others
the sensitivity the true positive rate
is only about 20 to 30 percent
uh so we wanted to get a high
specificity and improve the sensitivity
um to somewhere above 50 or 60 percent
um so
the combination of the two strand c 99
could potentially
achieve that because as i showed in the
tissue sections and
some of the blood the asteria is
elevated
in a complementary way to the c199
and so this could be used as i said for
differential diagnosis or for
surveillance amongst high risk people
where the prevalence is high enough to
make it
worthwhile now for prediction this would
be applied to patients considering
the way we've seen it based on our data
so far
they're pre they're considering um
chemotherapy and we've found that
uh the stra positive tumors are
resistant to standard chemotherapy
all right so beginning with slide 13 now
so our next step was to begin the panel
development
and blinded validation for the
goal of improving the sensitivity
of detection using high specificity
thresholds
this is a set of samples that we
published in our 2019 publication
these are samples that were collected
from
three different institutions comprising
ductal adenocarcinoma and controls that
were made up of healthy individuals as
well as
a wide variety of benign conditions of
the pancreas
now when we run the stra blood test it's
a sandwich immunoassay
and we run the sandwich amino acid
detecting the
stra glycan on a capture antibody
we have three different capture
antibodies that we use
as the base capture and then we detect
the strea glycan
on each of those three capture
antibodies
so one of the capture antibodies is the
ca199 antigen itself
so it's a sandwich amino acid in which
we capture c
199 and detect stra the others
are mucins that carry the glycan much
5ac and max16 so it's three
versions we do it this way because um
we do not have a good way of capturing
stra itself
um these three as individual markers
are each good individual markers
especially the one in red the
c99 stra and as an
individual marker it is slightly better
than c199
the key with all three of these
if you look at panel b now is that
they're complementary
and what we have here is in the x-axis
is standard c9 and the y-axis
is the stra antigen for each of these
three immunoassays and you'll see
that they are anti-correlated and and
this is good because we
the red dots are cancer black are the
controls
so you can see there are cancers that
are elevated in one or the other
is that it's that complementary nature
that means that if you bring them
together you're going to detect a higher
number of cancers
than either one alone so you don't want
them correlated because then they would
just detect the same cancer so this is
this is what we wanted to see
and now by setting the proper thresholds
for each of those markers
you can then detect a higher percentage
of patients in a panel c
that's what we did this is the same type
of graph where the
columns are patients the rows are the
markers top
row is c9 then we have um
the c99 str amino acid and then the monk
5ac str immunoassay
and you can see that the the second and
third rows
uh pick up some patients the yellow
means above threshold
the red is below and then the the
gray and blue row indicates um whether a
patient was elevated in any one
of the three so if a patient is elevated
in a one
or two or three of the three markers
it's classified as a case
and gray is is not and you can see that
there's a good sensitivity uh with the
highest specificity only two false
positives in the panel
for comparison c 199 alone
um did not do nearly as well at a
similar specificity
so um in the panel
training set next slide you'll see that
[Music]
um you'll see here that
we improved the sensitivity the 63
percent
over 47. this is a really good
performance actually for ca 99 i think
it just depends from set to set this was
a
set that uh had better than some other
sets that would be
more like 30 as i said um
and so this was setting our thresholds
and and
combination rules that we were using
then what we did was
we had another set that was blinded and
we ran
our assays and made calls without
knowing anything about the samples so we
sent back to the statistician we think
this is cancer we think this is control
this is the rigorous way to do the
validation
and then when we did that you'll see um
in the in the next
panel there that the performance of the
blinded calls
without any this is using the thresholds
derived from the training set making
blinded calls
we had a statistically significant
improvement in sensitivity over c 199
alone
this is the most rigorous validation
that can
be done and it's the first time that
there's been
this kind of validation of an
improvement upon ca 1999.
anytime any suggestion in the literature
has been made of improvement over c99
it's using
unblinded data data
analysis after the fact this is
using upfront predefined
thresholds and classification rules with
statistically significant improvement
this is in our 2019 publication we
followed this up on several sets now
we've seen this in
in many different sets of samples so
um we're quite confident that we have a
combination test
that improves upon c199
so we think that we're getting to the
level where
we could justify a
surveillance amongst high-risk people
where we would have high specificity
and enough sensitivity to make it worth
running the test and then the test would
lead to further up study further on
studies using imaging
so i'd like to tell you about
predicting chemotherapy responsiveness
using a pre-treatment blood test so
it's it's encouraging that um
using chemotherapy the modern
chemotherapies
there there are some responses
um we see about
30 to 40 percent of patients showing
good response
especially when the cancer is localized
um and they seem to have
extended life but there's and also
another
large group of patients that don't
respond at all
and have rapid relapse
this this is true for chemotherapy
applied
prior to surgery as well as after
surgery
if we had a test that could identify the
chemo resistant patients ahead of time
it would allow us to study alternative
treatments
develop patient-specific treatment plans
guide clinical trials also in model
systems and other
experimental therapeutics provide us a
way to
understand the biology of the
unresponsive cancers that subtype better
so we found here
in another study in which we were using
samples that were collected prior to
the beginning of neoadjuvant therapy
that we saw as individual markers we saw
elevations and cancer versus control
but the key was that
we saw more positives
in the patients that were non-responsive
or had
rapid relapse following chemotherapy
compared to those that did not and so
you see here that um the
using the the stra markers this
the three versions of stra we see
a high elevation in two or three markers
in 50 percent 50 to 60 percent of the
patients that had rapid relapse
and in a very low percentage of the
patients
that had long responses
so those are the controls on the right
very few of them only one or two are
elevated in more than one marker
but on the patients on the left where
they had
a rapid relapse so they're
non-responsive
um in the combined sets about
half of those patients were elevated in
two of the tests
so um
this is also shown in analysis of
survival curves where if they're
positive in the panel
so that's the patients that were blue
and the
um the bottom line the panel call was
positive
we see um they have a very there's a
line that has rapid decline
so very short survival versus the red
line those are panel negative
they had longer survival this is in two
independent sets now
uh c99 does not provide predictive
value this is well known for many
studies
we're just using this as a comparison
ca-199
is more of a tumor burden indicator
so it has some relationship with
prognosis but it doesn't tell you
anything about differences in subtype of
cancer
so it doesn't have any treatment
prediction value just some prognosis
value stra in contrast
has value for differentiating a
different
subtype of cancer that is more resistant
to chemotherapy
the blood data i'm showing you here
is backed up by a lot of data in cell
culture models where we show
cell culture models that are resistant
to
chemotherapy are high in the stra
and um this is what we see right here
is that in a panel of 27 cell lines
we have them divided by stra or c
199 or neither the
cell lines that are with the cyan
bars are stra positive cell lines we
have some that are both and then the
orange are
c99 over all the studies that we've done
in many different drug combinations
we see the ic50s or the resistance
is higher in multiple different drug
combinations including fall fear nox
gem cytobean others compared to the cell
lines that are
either positive in cn89 or
neither glycan
so currently in these two areas
we're working on clinical assay
development we've been able to port this
to
a clinical assay with standard curves
and controls
further testing and blinded sets we also
are working with pre-diagnostic sets
that means
serum samples that were collected prior
to any symptoms
any onset of symptoms this would be
replicating the situation where
we would be doing surveillance amongst
high-risk people
um we also on the prediction side we're
doing
further testing of the lead panels
and we're also using this in tissue
staining to
see if the tissue staining assays are
complementary to
the blood assays for treatment
prediction
so with that i'd like to thank the lab
members
this was led by dr jim von gao
and others in the lab who've done
excellent work
and my wonderful clinical collaborators
dr brandt at pittsburgh dr singhi
um many others doctors evans and psy
at medical college wisconsin
and all the others that you see here and
funding through the nci
primarily and other groups so
i thank you for listening and i'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you dr hop for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move to the live q a portion
of this presentation and as a reminder
please submit your questions
via the q a box dr hobb
where do you foresee the future clinical
use of biomarkers
in screening asymptomatic patients
with high risk of pancreatic cancer
the um screening of patients
um at high risk is already
taking place to some degree amongst
people with first degree relatives so
more than one first degree relative
but especially those with uh
genetics that put them in an even higher
risk group
it's not exactly clear how the genetic
markers
line up with the family history
um having both genetics and family
history put certainly put someone at a
higher risk
so um but in addition to people
at a hereditary risk there's also
clinical factors that puts somebody at a
higher risk
um so as with many different cancers
obesity
smoking but
chronic pancreatitis puts someone at a
higher risk
another clinical category is
new onset diabetes so it turns out that
patients
that have had some onset adult diabetes
within the past two years have an
increased risk
and the prevalence
of pancreatic cancer
could be as high as 0.5 to 0.8 percent
in that category um
the prevalence of cancer amongst people
with strong family history is
anywhere from one to two percent and so
these these categories
are are high enough prevalence
where um it would be justified it's
already been recommended by
a test for studying these issues um
where a
combination of a blood test with
follow-up
imaging um could be
effective and also uh justifiable from a
health care cost perspective uh
so we we think based on our modeling
that
if we have a test that gives 95 plus
percent specificity with 60
60 percent sixty percent plus
sensitivity
um followed up by that that would enrich
the prevalence to about ten percent or
more
which means that um
imaging tests one out of ten would
probably be
positive in cancer and that would
justify the use of imaging
so we see it being used
in one of these clinical or family
history categories
some of them have yet to be defined very
well
but there are enough high-risk
categories
uh where prevalence is anywhere between
0.5 to
1.5 percent where a test that
um with with similar performance to what
we have
could be justified so um the first goal
is to show that we can get that
performance
in patients who do not yet have symptoms
so
all of our data so far the patients have
symptoms they probably have a slightly
higher elevation
than people who would be one to two
years away from
developing symptoms so we need to get
that data and
we we have some samples
addressing that question so we're hoping
to get that data soon
thank you so much dr hob and thank you
to our audience for these great
questions
coming in dr hob how and when do you
recommend
and interpret the results of this
biomarker
so at the moment we think that this test
will be useful anytime you would order a
c99
so
[Music]
a patient has uh symptoms suggestive of
a pancreatic problem
and you're very familiar with
when to order ca 1989 to rule out cancer
or
or perhaps with very high elevation to
uh strongly suggest a diagnosis of
cancer so any time
or people are ordering c99 to monitor
reduction in levels or re-elevation
as i showed it's complementary meaning
that some patients that would be low in
c99 or fail to show an elevation
um would show an elevation in this one
or
in both and so uh anytime
that you would order a c 199 for
a confirmation or ruling out diagnosis
or monitoring
you would order this one too and the
nice thing is it's only one
additional test so the cost is not going
to be
very much higher than just ca 1999
the interpretation well i will say
though that in
an additional area where it would be
ordered would be
we hope and in determining
chemotherapy regimen whether it be
standard chemotherapy or
a trial or some alternate version where
the patient's high in
stra would be predicted to be
resistant to first line chemotherapy
the interpretation is it is
much higher in adenocarcinoma compared
to
any other disease of the pancreas that
we've looked at so far
possibly some mucinous tumors elevated
as well
high grade ipmns potentially
elevated in some cases we've seen a few
neural endocrine
carcinomas elevated as well but
not enough of a high percentage that it
would certainly indicate a
neuroendocrine cancer it's much more
prevalent
in adenocarcinoma so i think
i think it would be interpreted as
strongly suggestive
of adenocarcinoma particularly at high
levels of elevation
and um it would be then suggestive
of a treatment resistant version
of adenocarcinoma
thank you dr hob and we have time for
one more question
our next audience member asks actually a
two-part question
what are your thoughts about the current
pancreatic cancer screening methods for
example
imaging and biopsy and then what are the
gaps
in the current screening protocol
um well imaging
followed by biopsy um
it seems to be useful when the
prevalence is
is high enough and it does seem to
catch incipient cancer in some cases and
and it seems um justified
in a strong family history setting
but i think if you were going to
try to apply that type of protocol to
patients more the clinical risk like
from
chronic pancreatitis or new onset
diabetes i think
the prevalence of disease in those
categories would be too low to justify
the cost of screening see because those
the imaging
is a lot more expensive than a blood
test so you you need to
use it more sparingly so i i think
currently no one wants to make a
diagnosis unless they
have an imaging confirmation and if
possible biopsy
confirmation of the biopsy has great
challenges with the pancreas because
of the difficulty in obtaining a good
biopsy
often the correct area is missed and
even if cells are obtained it can be
inconclusive because of the quality of
the sample so
and it can also induce a lot of um has
risk of
side effects um introducing other
problems some morbidity
so we're seeding the tumor so pancreatic
biopsy is by no means
totally easy foolproof benign procedure
so the blood test really has to use a
huge advantages
over that um so we we hope that
a good blood test being used in
combination with imaging and or biopsy
would be
a great improvement over just those
other methods
and what was the other part what are the
gaps
in the screening protocol
um i think i think the the gap is
a good low cost blood test
um so that's where we're hoping to fill
in that gap
because c99 is not good enough to be
used
in screening so certainly a low-cost
blood test used in combination with
imaging biopsy
is a huge gap um
and just the fact that um it seems like
there is a subtype
of adenocarcinomas that don't elevate
any marker that we know of and that
really seemed to be a different subtype
all together
and so uh developing some better
understanding of
all the subtypes of pancreatic
adenocarcinoma
is is a big goal we we know
for sure a couple of these subtypes as
tra seems to be elevated more in one of
them
stra and there's a much work going on
in other areas about subtypes so it
seems like there's
a group of cancers where it's very hard
to understand
exactly what the nature of that subtype
is and there's no good way to detect
them so
i would say a low-cost blood test and
just a better understanding
of all of the subtypes of endocarcinoma
dr hobb i want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide our audience with any closing
remarks
before we end today um
so just keep keep watching on what we're
doing um
this is really an up-and-coming
biomarker
and um i'm hopeful that this will
be valuable for patients and doctors and
and
help the field so thank you very much
thank you dr brian hubb thank you again
for your presentation and for your
important research
and i want to thank our audience members
for their outstanding questions today
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative
and insightful this presentation will be
available
on demand viewing don't miss out on the
other valuable presentations on our
agenda
and visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full
listing thank you again for your
participation until next time
take care be safe bye-bye